make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today we're going to shift our focus to
the DC Universe which you've kind of
been doing this week and discuss one of
Superman's most absurd villains mister
Mixel pedelec now if you've watched our
videos over the course of the week you
know that mr. mitchell pedelec was
exceedingly powerful but if you're new
here to this whole series mr. mixon
pedelec was created by Jerry Siegel and
Joe Shuster and first appeared in
Superman number 30 in 1944 now he comes
from the fifth dimension where our laws
of physics do not apply as his first
appearance was in the Golden Age of
comics when heroes like Superman were in
stories that were really just one issue
long before moving on to the next issue
we don't really get a ton of continuity
or backstory now when mr. mixup pedelec
shows up he just plays a series of jokes
on Superman in order to just irritate
him but even though those jokes are
meant to be humorous they actually give
us some insight into his parallel for
instance he's able to alter his own
weight so that he's too heavy for
paramedics to pick up and change the
voice of the mayor to that of a donkey
while these don't seem too impressive at
first they do clue us in to the fact
that Mixel pedelec is capable of
altering reality what little bit we do
learn about his background in this issue
is that he's a jester in the fifth
dimension which is why he has such an
infinity for playing jokes now as for
most of his appearances that he makes
especially the earliest ones he
basically just shows up to annoy
Superman before being sent back to his
home dimension when Superman tricks him
into saying his name backwards now mix
up it elects origin is first explored in
Young Justice number three by Peter
David where it's revealed that he is a
time-traveling researcher who finds out
about his future and decides not to
annoy Superman but instead devote his
life to learning this had a drastic
effect on the timeline and plunged earth
into a post-apocalyptic state realizing
the cause of this desolate future was
the absence of Mixel hillocks encounters
with Superman members of Young Justice
robbing Superboy and impulse figure out
that his sense of humor has not yet been
developed so they expose him to a Three
Stooges movie and so after viewing the
film Mixel pedelec develops a love of
slapstick humor and vows to return to
annoy Superman periodically and thereby
fixes the timeline now like nearly every
character Mixel petallics
origin is changed by the new 52 reboot
across DC Comics from 2011 and it's at
this point that we learned that he's a
wizard in the 5th dimension for his job
was to entertain the king now one of the
primary ways he did this was by
designing challenges for heroes in a
variety of
wolves with the one that was the most
successful and therefore the most
entertaining to the king being Superman
now the favor of Mixel pedelec gains
with the king causes his former court
magician bindas soon to become insanely
jealous and plot to kill him but would
actually kill the king by mistake and so
eventually Mixel pedelec would come to
be the king of the fifth dimension
himself but would basically be stuck in
a time loop as he would later be
entertained by a jester named mix of hit
Alec and killed by villains in naik
sepeda lick was also a key figure in the
rebirth publishing initiative which was
more of a soft reboot of the DC Universe
one of the key storylines of the reboot
revolved around the appearance of a
second Clark Kent in Metropolis the
identity of this imposter is revealed to
be mixed up Italy who just been
imprisoned by a man named mr. Oz who is
actually Superman's father jor-el and so
he escapes and gets angry the Superman
didn't notice that he was gone and so he
transforms himself into Clark Kent and
then brainwashes himself into believing
that he is Clark Kent he sets up a
challenge for Superman which culminates
in the merging of the new 52 and pre
flashpoint versions of Superman and Lois
Lane sometimes don't want to throw out
here that I kind of want to talk about
here for a second is the action comics
and Superman rebirth line of comics
here's the thing guys Superman had not
really been interesting following the
death of his character and even before
that he hadn't really been interested
Superman wasn't really interesting since
the 1950s right like you go into
basically everything after Julius
Schwartz kinda did this whole reworking
of Superman's character in 1970s one
more Weisinger left and he had just not
been interesting at all ever since that
point but then you go into DC Universe
rebirth it's probably the best romance
storytelling there's been in decades
right for decades and decades and
decades
Superman's stories weren't that great
and then we get some amazing stories
even the most staunch Superman fans
would have to admit his stories weren't
that great before and DC Universe
rebirth was mind-blowing and so what did
DC do in response to all that popularity
they kicked off the riders and replacing
my Brian Michael Bendis who did a
terrible job so yeah that's kind of
where we are right now
Superman kind of sucks again but for
Mixel pittle expires he's able to work
reality in any way that he can dream up
in the Silver Age of comics this was
attributed to a magical ability which
was why Superman was so susceptible to
his hijinks but has also been explained
as just being a product of existing in a
fifth dimension beyond those who were
able to perceive in other words the fact
that we exist in three dimensions makes
it
seem as if things from the fifth
dimension are magic he's seemingly
immortal as he's tried to kill himself
by giving up his powers and summoning
doomsday to take him out and even when
he's killed by doomsday he immediately
comes back to life
to that end Mixel pillock does not
require air water or food to survive and
it is impossible to deal any physical
damage to him as with all the many
reality warping characters that we've
covered in the series it's really not
feasible to list all of his powers
because what he can do is limited only
by his imagination he's unbound by the
laws of physics and by the very concept
of time as he's able to take all of the
Earth's gravity away and can move
forward and backward in time at will
he's able to travel into other
dimensions as well for instance he can
enter the pages of a comic book or
become a character in a television show
he frequently breaks the fourth wall
indicating that he's aware of reality
outside the DC Comics multiverse and has
even been able to interact with the
writers of an issue of Superman now
theoretically Mixel pedelec can do
anything and we see an example of what
he's theoretically capable of in the
Earth's world's title of world's funnest
which you'll find out in the description
because we just finished covering this
week and while it's not really part of
DC Canon does it really matter when
you're dealing with a character who can
do anything it doesn't really matter
whether there's Canon or not but in that
series we saw a Mixel pedelec hit the
specter over the head with the earth and
then he and that might literally tear
the universe apart after that they go
through all the various universes of the
DC multiverse and destroy them so like
earth 3 where the crime syndicate is the
Dark Knight Returns universe the DC
Animated universe all of them are
totally destroyed and then remade and so
mixed pedelec is depicted as being
effectively omnipotent here granted this
is an else world story so it's not canon
but it is a version of the care - that
exists so I suddenly wanted to throw it
out there now at the end of the day
Mixel pedelec is certainly the most
powerful of Superman's foes and is only
because his desire to have fun and
Superman's expense that he isn't
perceived that way if he really was a
truly evil character instead of just
playfully antagonistic he'd be able to
do some exceedingly dangerous damage if
you want an example of what mix of
piddly could do if he was motivated by
evil just go check out my beyond Omega
level video on Emperor Joker which is a
story where Joker stole 99% of Mixel
petallics power and was able to rewrite
reality in his image and he's able to
subjugate Darkseid ganthet high father
Zeus and the Phantom Stranger who were
some of the most
powerful entities and the entirety of DC
Comics and so the spectre even said that
Emperor Joker would be capable of
destroying the universe and that he
actually follows through on doing so and
then remakes the universe and so it
stands to reason that mix of Hitler
would be capable of doing these things
as well if he chose to and so it was
lucky for Superman that he's more
interested in playing practical jokes on
him instead of destroying all of reality
over that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comment explain make sure
you guys are the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
make sure you check out the comments
section leave some comments down below
for what future characters you want me
to cover
now we'll catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]